welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul aka the guy who got
recasters definition
and this video we're breaking down some
more big one division theories
the ending of the last episode was
enough to give anyone whiplash
and actually points out a possible way
that vision could have been brought back
to life
throughout this video we're going to be
discussing that what the blip proves and
why
sword may be trying to recreate ultron
if you love this video 3000 i'd
massively appreciate the thumbs up
and don't forget to subscribe for
breakdowns like this each and every week
on the wonderful world of west view
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into the video
okay so firstly i want to discuss how
vision may be alive
he's the only character other than
thanos who's been killed twice
and yet somehow he's still playing
father knows best at wonders side
we had been wondering for some time
exactly what happened to him
and episode 5 revealed that wandered had
wandered into sword
and taken his body out of their lab
which we will be discussing later in the
video
vision seems to be alive and well
however without the mind stone i can't
think of any real way that she could
have brought him back without magical or
mystical means
in the case of sparky it was made
abundantly clear that wonder could not
resurrect the dead
and therefore i'm not sure if she had
anything to do with his return
now one of the most popular theories is
that vision was actually brought back by
the grim reaper
i've already gone in depth on this
several times and has his helmet
featured in the intro to episode 2
the clues are there he also appeared
heavily in the vision and skull at which
graphic novel
that this series is based upon so it
does seem quite likely that he may be
behind it in some way
however episode 5's ending also revealed
another possibility
in it we saw that evan peters's
quicksilver had been brought across
from another reality in avengers end
game we also saw through gamora that it
was possible to bring people across from
another timeline who had died
and therefore the vision that we see
could be an alternate version of the
character
now i just want to shout out azwin for
commenting this on my last video and
after going back over certain scenes in
the series
it could indeed be correct we know that
the show is opening up the multiverse
before it spans off into spider-man 3
and doctor strange 2 so yeah they are
starting to lay the groundwork similar
to wonder
vision doesn't know how he got there and
perhaps he was pulled across from
another world
and then had his memory erased so that
he would be unaware
and unable to warn wonder about what was
really going on
there are several clues that whoever is
behind this entire thing
has been trying to make one to have
children no matter what
and in order to do so they have provided
her with several subliminal suggestions
and distractions just as she envisioned
were about to have a big argument that
could have potentially split them up
evan peters showed up out of nowhere and
thus i don't think that wonder was
behind bringing him back
in the same way that some force brought
him across they could have also brought
across
vision so that she had a reason to stay
i'm assuming that one of the major
conflicts that will arise from the show
is that west view shouldn't exist and it
will likely end with doctor strange
coming to shut things down before they
spiral out of control
destroying this will of course mean that
vision has to go and as we know that
wonder will be an antagonist in the
multiverse of madness
it definitely makes sense for her to be
angry that her husband had to be sent
back
and that she has to remain in the
universe where he's still dead
now as for the dead vision it's clear
that sword were up to something
as when we saw footage of wonder
invading their headquarters
he was on an operating table being
sliced up into several
sections when vision died his body was
whole
and in the timeline of the mcu his death
happened five years prior
so it makes no sense as to why they'd
bring him back out and start
experimenting on him
unless they had ulterior motives i
actually got talking to ryan arie from
screen crush about this
who started going into how he too
thought that sword were trying to
weaponize his corpse
i've put our conversation up if you want
to pause the video and read it
and it's also in front of a picture of
hayward because i bloody hate him
brian that's your mom
[Laughter]
now i kind of built up on this theory
and said that i think they're trying to
recreate ultron
and he asked why make another murderbot
which i didn't really have an answer to
because i bloody hate him gotcha sucker
however after thinking about it i think
that the answer is
clear and that is because of thanos
ultron was originally created as a
reaction to the battle of new york to
ensure that nothing like that could ever
happen again
unfortunately the machine believed that
the only way to get peace was to wipe
out humanity
but juxtaposing this vision saw the good
in people
i think that sword realized that because
of the snap that they needed a better
form of protection for the planet
and that what they had simply wasn't
good enough you have to realize that in
the mcu timeline
everyone is probably completely
terrified because thanos managed to wipe
out half of all life in the universe
with a snap of his fingers
perhaps sword realized that tony had a
point all the way back in the second
avengers movie
and decided to try and roll with it and
put a giant suit of armor around the
world
knowing that vision isn't as homicidal
as his father was
they probably wanted to reprogram him in
order to be the ultron that we should
have got
whilst also standing as something that
they could control
now as we know from vision's will he
didn't want to be weaponized
and thus wonder going to him was likely
saving him from this fate
we know from seeing her in west view
that she doesn't want to turn him into a
living weapon
so i think this line of dialogue was
brought in by the writers to highlight
what is really going on
in the entire situation from what we
know of hayward he has completely
changed the way that sword operate
and instead of looking to the stars
they've now started to turn their
attention to earth
not only does this fit in with the idea
as to why they try and rebuild an ultron
type figure
it also makes sense as to why they would
want to weaponize vision
against his wishes as speaking of the
blip seeing it from monica's perspective
definitely does clear up a lot of things
john campio recently did a video
discussing how elements of it worked
that i want to discuss in more depth but
i think the scene itself shows how
things happened
when the blip happened a lot of people
had questions about those being brought
back
and one of the big situations that
people struggled with were those who
were on airplanes when they got snapped
for example if someone was at 20 000
feet in the air when they went missing
surely when they returned they'd be back
in the same space right
wrong because of a person in the
hospital who materialized on a stretcher
we now know that people are brought back
in the context of how they vanished
but not in the exact same position thus
if you were on a plane when you got
snapped
you'd probably be brought back on one
midair or a grounded one
so you didn't end up miles and miles
away from where you live
taking this on a grander scale the world
itself is basically a rock that's
spinning through space
and it would be highly unlikely that if
one were blipped back that the planet
itself would be in the exact same
spot as when they were when they
vanished so it's simply the context that
they disappeared in which decides how
they return
monica just so happened to be at her
mother's bedside
but it's nigh on impossible that people
just happen to be pushing a stretcher in
the exact same place
that a man who wasn't one disappeared so
we can stop talking about that now
we can just all chill out and you you
can finally rest
and lastly i want to discuss a theory
from new rock stars that you could see
mephisto's hand in the reflection of a
mirror
before evan peters came across i've
watched this footage
over and over again and personally i
think that it might be a mic that was
left in this shot in order to try and
capture the audio for the scene
i'm not 100 on that and new rock stars
do great videos so i'm not slagging them
off like that's some of a bit ryanairy
i'm just not sure exactly what it is and
i also think that the lad
eric boss will be like a boss and
probably tell you that he's not 100
either
still oh definitely an interesting
talking point and i hope this video is
giving you some stuff to think about
and obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts below now don't forget that on
the 28th of february we're giving away
three copies of the phase three mcu 4k
box set to our subscribers
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications
on and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the theories the winners of
last month's competition are on screen
right now
so that's you then message me on twitter
heavyspoilers
the links to our socials are in the
description and you can also support the
channel by clicking the join button
and as a thank you you get videos like
this early if you want something else to
watch
then make sure you check out our other
theories video which we dropped over the
weekend
which talks about how hayward might be
in hydra and a lot more stuff
without the way thank you for sending
through the video i mean paul i see you
next time
take care peace